[Music]
Disney Princesses are made out to be the
embodiment of perfection however even a
fictional character can have trouble
abiding to these impossible standards
watch until the end to find out which
Disney Princess was only 14 years old on
her wedding day
before we dive into 20 things about
Disney Princesses that don't make sense
make sure you subscribe to the things
and give us a big thumbs up Elsa's
powers princess also realized that she
was different from a very young age
unlike her younger sister Anna she had
the ability to manipulate ice in magical
ways seeing as Anna was her closest and
dearest friend she got her in on a
secret
but soon lived to regret it while it is
truly amazing that Elsa has magical
powers their origins are never explained
why is it that Elsa is the ice princess
and Anna isn't it makes no sense
Jasmine returns to the palace after
running away at only 16 years old
Princess Jasmine was told that she would
soon be made to Wed soon after meeting
Aladdin and revealing her true identity
Jasmine was returned to the palace
despite the circumstances she met on the
road jasmine was still a bride-to-be
however this didn't seem to bother her
the second time around instead of
running away after the news of Aladdin's
death she decided to meet with
impossible suitors so - Jasmine's day in
Agrabah scare her back to her riches or
is this a plot hole that Disney decided
to sidestep Mulan was dismissed from the
army
Mulan's brave actions were justified by
the love she had for her father who had
just been summoned to war for the second
time I've been previously been injured
caused Milan's dad to walk with the cane
which wasn't exactly ideal for the
battlefield
Milan's captain eventually deemed her
unfit to fight and dismissed her from
her war duties this causes us to ask
ourselves wouldn't Ilan's dad have been
deemed unfit to fight as well Pocahontas
speaks fluent English as many Disney
Princesses eventually find out love is
the strongest weapon of all
when Pocahontas first met John Smith she
knew that their encounter was lead to a
series of unfortunate events John Smith
was eventually placed on death row by
her tribe but this didn't stop her from
sheltering his body seconds before his
execution if you kill him you'll have to
kill me too
while her actions were brave and true
is one piece of the puzzle that just
doesn't make sense this being that both
she and John were able to communicate
with one another
after all a tribe of natives shouldn't
be able to speak the English language
mogera falls in love again when Magus
first introduced into the Hercules
thought line we're led to believe that
she's a sweet and innocent victim
however it is soon revealed that she's
working with Hades the god of the
underworld while many of us were quick
to judge her our opinions changed when
we found out that she was enslaved by
Hades not willingly helping him you see
mag had sold her soul to him in order to
save the life of her ex-boyfriend the
man who she believed to be her soul mate
then left her for someone else
and she vowed to never make the same
mistake twice unfortunately for Meg she
was unable to stay true to her promise
Cinderella's shoe this Disney Princess
moment makes no sense at all which is
why it has plagued many of us since we
were kids
surely you remember how Princess
Cinderella lost her shoe while trying to
get back to her carriage before midnight
while losing her glass slipper gave
Prince Charming a chance to locate his
one true love it also caused some plot
holes to arise for starters why would a
shoe that was made to be a perfect fit
slip off secondly how is it possible
that Cinderella was the only made man
the entire kingdom to wear this exact
shoe size think this is weird watch
until the end to uncover the strangest
Cinderella scene of all Ariel is the
mermaid while we hate to state the
obvious we figured that it was time to
do just that Ariel is one of the most
beloved Disney Princesses of all time
however she isn't exactly human don't
you think it's just a little weird that
every single Disney Princess is human
except for her who we sure do while it's
true that Ariel did everything in her
power to walk amongst the humans we
can't deny her true heritage despite all
this the Little Mermaid goes to show
that we don't get to choose who we fall
in love with but we do get to choose to
follow our hearts Rapunzel could easily
have been found let's put aside the fact
that Rapunzel's hair has magical
properties and focus on the bigger
picture she was kidnapped at birth by a
villain this wicked villain posed as
Rapunzel's mother and spread false lies
about the world outside the tower this
kept Princess Rapunzel from venturing
outdoors but not forever
if there's one thing that just doesn't
make sense about tangled is that
Rapunzel's real parents never thought to
send out
search parties to the woods around their
kingdom should they have they would have
encountered a strange tower and found at
the lost princess inside of its val
lives in France but doesn't have an
accent princess Belle always knew that
she was different from the other girls
her age however she was also aware that
there was nothing wrong with being
different
instead of pining after handsome men and
lowering her morals Belle sought to
acquire knowledge in the shape of books
having been raised by a single father
caused her to feel very protective over
him this is why she offered herself as
tribute when her dad was taken captive
by the Beast
despite Belle being born and raised in
France the princes never spoke with the
slightest inkling of a French accent
which just doesn't add up
there are only eleven Disney Princesses
with so many female Disney leads it's a
wonder that some of them don't fall
under the Disney princess category as a
matter of fact only eleven of them do
this means that heroines like mogera
Anna Moana Alice and many more aren't
allowed to add the princess title to
their names this seems rather strange
which leads us to ask ourselves what
does it take to become a princess while
the easy answer is marrying royalty or
being royalty characters like Mulan and
Pocahontas are still considered to be
princesses do you have any thoughts on
this Disney hiccup if so let us know
what being a princess means to you in
the comments what kind of a princess are
you school doesn't seem to be an issue
for Disney Princesses if there's one
thing that we've noticed throughout
dozens of Disney movies is that
characters aren't exactly encouraged to
go to school since teaching our youth
about the importance of education is a
must
many parents have raised an eyebrow
towards this topic could it be that Walt
Disney didn't believe in education if so
he made that clear by preventing every
single Disney princess from pursuing her
studies
sure Belle might like to read but does
she do this in a school setting or not
for now it seems that being a princess
and going to school don't go hand in
hand
Arielle has six sisters it's easy to
forget that Princess Ariel isn't the
only daughter of King Triton and Queen
Athena this is because the Little
Mermaid only has eyes for Ariel as the
youngest out of seven sisters Ariel
shouldn't be the main focus nonetheless
she steals the show 100 percent of the
time it's only normal for Ariel's older
sisters to be jealous of all the
attention she gets from their father
however they don't seem to mind
in the end any jealousy they might have
felt would have been released when she
moved out of the ocean and on to dry
land
the fairy godmothers spell when
Cinderella's fairy godmother came to
save the day she left her with one
simple warning on the stroke of twelve
the spell will be broken while this
seems like an easy rule to follow
Cinderella lost track of time and nearly
revealed her true identity to Prince
Charming since her clothing jewelry and
carriage were solely made out of magic
everything was said to disappear by the
time the clock struck midnight
as promised her gown wins from riches to
rags in seconds and did everything else
she possessed with one exception
Cinderella's glass slipper remained on
the scene which contradicted everything
her fairy godmother had promised without
this plot hole however Prince Charming
would have never have found his princess
Moana survives the fall into the realm
of monsters Moana might be an
independent woman but there's only so
much she can do against the laws of
gravity it's customary for cartoons to
abide by different rules
however some actions warrant death or
broken bones did any of you find it
weird when Moana jumped into the realm
of monsters from a towering height only
to survive we sure did here we think
that Maui would have used his magics to
help Moana slowly drift into the pits
however keeping her out of harm's way
was never one of his priorities the
ocean might have mallanna's back but
there weren't any waves present to break
her fall
Aurora's baby shower when Princess
Aurora was born her parents King Stefan
and Queen Leah vowed to protect her with
their lives however they did the
opposite of this by refraining to invite
the evil fairy Maleficent to their
newborn babies ceremony moments before
Fairy Merryweather could bless baby
Aurora with a gift
Maleficent put a curse on her this curse
promised that Aurora would prick her
finger on a magical spinning wheel on
her 16th birthday and die while the
curse was softened by fairy Merryweather
it could have been avoided all together
all Maleficent wanted was to be invited
to Aurora's ceremony like the rest of
the kingdom had been so basically King
Stefan and Queen Leah messed up big-time
Belle falls in love with an animal when
it comes down to it Disney movies don't
always hold the most logical plots but
hey we're not complaining
princess Belle had the opportunity to
marry one of the most handsome men in
her village
marry me whoever this fact mattered very
little to her all she wanted was to fall
in love with someone she could share
wonderful conversations with while
falling for a huge and ugly beast wasn't
her plan this is exactly what happened
many homophobic critics were quick to
point out that Lefou was in love with
Gaston however one pointed out that
Belle had romantic feelings for an
animal and her captor nonetheless
Princess Charlotte didn't become a frog
princess Charlotte's from The Princess
and the Frog might not be the main focus
of the movie but she's still an
important character problem is Charlotte
loses her princess title after midnight
and this is when she gives the Frog
Prince a big smooch as legend goes
anyone who kisses the frog prince will
turn into a frog themselves unless they
are a princess knowing this Charlotte
would have transformed into a frog just
like Tiana dead for some odd reasons
though she remains in her human state
was this a mistake or what Aurora's
family was borned about the curse when
the evil fairy Maleficent found out that
she was not invited to princess Aurora's
ceremony she kind of lost her marbles so
much so that she barged into the Kings
Hall and planted a wicked curse on the
newborn baby
this curse went as followed Princess
Aurora will prick her finger on the
spindle of a magical wheel and die
before the Sun sets on her 16th birthday
after hearing this tragic curse you
would think that Aurora would be
supervised on her 16th birthday but she
wasn't instead she was left to her own
devices which resulted with the princess
falling into an enchanted sleep
Ariel put the entire ocean in danger for
selfish reasons when Princess Ariel
first laid eyes on Prince Eric she
couldn't help but fall in love Ariel
might have been a young teenager at the
time but surely she had a sense of right
and wrong her need to become human was
so intense that she sought out an evil
sea witch and surrendered her voice to
her while Ariel might be portrayed as
brave this act is also seen as selfish
after all she did put the entire ocean
in danger to get what she so desperately
wanted I want to be
where the people are Snow White is only
14 years old Snow White was only 14
years old when her stepmother became
threatened by her beauty despite her
efforts to keep snow's beauty at bay it
could not be contained this prompted the
evil queen to hire a huntsman to kill
her competition however as her young age
and beauty was too much for the Huntsman
to bear now we don't know what's worse
the fact that a 14-year old was the
fairest of them all or that she got
married before her 15th birthday who's
your favorite Disney Princess drop her
name in the comment section and that's
it for 20 things about Disney Princesses
that make no sense at all
if you enjoyed this video subscribe to
our channel for more amazing content
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]